COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER. USUALLY
ADVISE AN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY FOR STUDENTS
BEING MADE. THERE'S ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT HERE FLORA
HERE GIVE SENT HERE KAMLAGER
LEE PRESENT. LEVINE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS RAMOS YOUR VEHICLE THE
APPROVED WHAT HERE WE HAVE A
CAR WE HAVE A QUORUM- WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA SO MOVE A MOVE
BY MR GIPSON SECONDED BY MR.
RAMOS MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM. SENATE GONNA HI
FLORA FLORA HIGH GIPSON HI
GIPSON HI KAMLAGER LEAVE. LEAVE
HI LEVINE. LEVINE HI
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN HAI
MATHIS RAMOS. RAMOS FIVE YOU
PUT WHAT YOU COULD Y. MOTION
PASSES. MOST PASSED AND- CALLER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL
REMAIN HERE FOR A MOMENT. BOB.
MATHIS OUR MATHIS I. CUNNINGHAM
I'VE CUNNINGHAM HIGH.